Kevin Hart digit a pictu I'm Kevin Hart
and I i know martial arts
gregory seal before [ __ ] me i don't i
don't know any hey Kevin Hart I speak
seven languages um I can't
I'm sorry I lied again before I really
I'm gonna dedicate this to my aunt who
passed away no she didn't she didn't
pass away Back to the Future audition
take one what a weight the way did I see
him and I can kind of put script thing
is if I can almost manic ah what do you
mean no no we gotta leave now house hair
if I had hair we gotta go back to 1998 I
want to dance with MC Hammer I'm sorry
Kevin Hart Dark Knight Rises take two I
am reading for the part of bein quick
question does does he does he does he
[ __ ] Batman I didn't see black until I
was already mine but if they wanted to
like put some stuff in there by then it
was nothing to me but blinding no sexual
stuff
oh you think you kick [ __ ] I made notes
on these I'm sorry this is
main is a dog right that's way the way I
read it I saw baiting the dog I nailed
it I feel really good about that I'm
about to call my dad
do not oh yeah I'm calling wait till we
give you everything I'm about to tell my
dad I'm about to [ __ ] Batman